ce train mes chers collègues vous ne
m'en voudrez pas monsieur le ministre
mais ma question sur ce sujet des
retraites qui agite et inquiète notre
pays tout entier s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre je n'irai pas par quatre
chemins votre réforme des retraites est
une mauvaise réforme mauvaise parce que
vous avez mis la charrue avant les
boeufs la priorité aurait dû être de
régler la question du déficit mauvaise
parce que les régimes spéciaux en
sortent renforcées alors même que
emmanuel macron le 4 octobre dernier à
rodez affirmait il n'y aura plus de
régimes spéciaux mauvaise parce que
votre système
au delà des discours dont on voit la
faible durée de vie va appauvrir les
retraités
le point est volatile les femmes et les
familles y perdront parfois beaucoup et
les pensions de réversion ne seront
versés qu'à 62 ans mauvaise parce qu à
des régimes différents vous substituer
une inégalité entre les générations
parce que les travailleurs indépendants
devront cotiser plus parce qu'il est
indispensable de maintenir nos régimes
complémentaires comme partout en europe
nous serions les seuls à avoir un régime
étatisé et unique
enfin et ce n'est pas le moindre parce
que vous sortez les plus hauts revenus
d'un système par répartition qui
contribuait à assurer notre ciment
national alors
n'avez-vous pas le sentiment monsieur le
premier ministre qui lie à un fossé
entre l'engagement premier d'emmanuel
macron de ne pas toucher à l'âge légal
les objectifs affichés d'universalité et
de justice et la réalité des
conséquences de votre projet pour les
français
[Applaudissements]